talking about the modern day in mill
wall and stuff that happens now
just coming out the back end of a
pandemic hopefully
uh
a lot of pandemics in the middle ages a
lot of those running around in the
middle ages yeah
i mean
the big ones the black death of the 14th
century
nearly at the end though they just
picked the post you know they only had
100 years before rome got wrecked again
and then they'd have been missed off
they'd have been in whatever comes after
well there's an argument that says no
black death uh
a a much delayed renaissance and
you know
the the counterfactual with no black
death is very very very hard to play
um
so i it's not as
it can't be
we can't be too certain
that uh had the black death not come
along you would still have seen the sack
of roma 1527.
but in answer to your first question
the the big pandemics of the middle ages
yeah you've got like black death of the
mid 14th century and then the waves all
the way through to 1390s
and
much earlier than that in fact
years earlier than that you have the
justinianic plague playing justinian
harder really to be certain about it's
it's spread it's virulence much more
much more reliant on impressionistic
evidence
what's the justinianic play well
the accounts of chroniclers saying oh my
god it was terrible there was like mad
lockdowns and thousands of people
dying all the time
um
you know there's there is
far less
like i can get super nerdy so
the justinian justinianic plague of the
sixth century a.d
seems to have been similar to the black
death in that it was a form of
bubonic plagues
which
mutated very very very infectious and
very very very deadly
the trouble is
we know a lot about the black death and
very little about the justinianic plague
a lot of what we have to surmise about
the justinianic plague
is surmised by taking what we know of
the black death and then
transposing its
say its rate of spread and its lethality
back onto the fragments of evidence we
have from the sixth century
so that the range of estimates of how
many people
so with the black death of the 14th
century we know with a reasonable degree
of certainty that it's uh
50 60 percent of the population of
western europe are killed by the black
death
we can we can be quite certain about
that although it varies from place to
place we'd be quite certain about that
however because of the fragmentary
nature of the evidence about the sixth
century
justinianic plague
you're sort of using models from the
14th century and putting them on top of
very very
scant evidence and and so
the high range of estimates for deaths
in the adjusting that plague i think
runs to like 100 million but the low
range runs to about 50 000.
good confidence interval
well it's a problem right
now if you just read the chroniclers
of the from the sixth century
that tallies with this idea that it's
closer to 100 million than 50
000. but the trouble is that chroniclers
we don't tend to trust chroniclers and
they tend to
get a bit hot under the collar i mean if
you only had daily mail and or son or
guardian editorials to go by as your as
your historical source you would have a
somewhat warped idea about the history
of
the current pandemic right
you want some stats you want some data
man give me some data give me some hard
data
chronic chronicles is that not what
chroniclers are supposed to do it's kind
of in the name chronicling things not
pundits punditras that wasn't their name
yes but there's so um
but if you take a we we would call say
procopius of caesarea a chronicler
um
he'd fall into under that broad term
because he writes histories
uh and contemporary histories of what
he's living through in the age of
justinian
but the guy is
much closer to
a
paid by the inch
um
[Music]
like shock columnist gossip gossip
no not gossip
i mean a sort of a like a rented opinion
it's not quite katie hopkins well as as
was before she got back or he's like
piers morgan right all right yeah what's
the issue of the day morgan's got two
takes and he just like goes okay that
one
uh
and
he's he's absolutely brilliant i mean
totally amoral as a journalist i don't
know personally maybe a nice guy may not
be i don't know but um
as a journalist he's brilliant
because he's either
like completely enraging
or completely sympathetic depending on
where you stand on on this particular
issue
and procopius caesar is sort of similar
very very similar to piers morgan
so if you take it here's a good example
of this
could be a caesar is is you know
supposedly a chronicler well he's just
writing what happened
like morgan would say i'm just a
journalist you know
um
spends half his career
toadying up unbelievably
to justinian the emperor unbelievably
yeah the sort of flatterer the kind of
writing
the histories of the wars of justinian
and kind of blowing endless smoke up the
empress
and then he writes the secret history
which is like uh
the most
offensive
damning
um
tell all expose character assassination
mudslinging
like horror show
of an account of justinian and theodore
uh
which
smears them absolutely smears them i
mean it's so entertaining it's great
but it's like a hell of a flip-flop
um
and people sort of scratch their heads
oh this is you know what what's going on
with prokopius to caesarea man just look
at piers morgan and megan okay the dude
couldn't get his nose out of her uh
and then she kind of snubbed him and so
he becomes her worst enemy it's an old
story it's an old story
um but it's
you know so anyway the point was is you
know chroniclers don't know they don't
just chronicle of course
their opinion
yeah that was that's that's the old
fashion you've shown your age there yeah
you're stin
you grew up in the age of spin spinny
hendricks it's because i love the thick
of it that's why thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace